[Music]
welcome
to the week in 60 minutes brought to you
by spectator tv
recorded thursday february the 11th
on this week's show nearly 13 million
brits have now
received their first vaccine daily
covert cases have fallen to around 20
000 and daily deaths are almost at new
year levels
the more contagious and deadly variants
of the coronavirus
could still threaten progress we'll
start by bringing you the latest data
from the pandemic
from kate andrews and we'll speak to
professor sharon peacock who chairs the
uk's
genomics consortium then we'll turn to
scotland
the smp is beleaguered by inquiries and
infighting but it continues to pull
far away above the opposition with
critical hollywood elections in may
coming up
which would give nicola sturgeon the
mandate she wants for a second
referendum
we'll speak to douglas ross leader of
the scottish conservatives about the
battle
unionists face following that our
political team will help us unpack the
discussion
and they'll give us the latest from
westminster too
and we'll finish by talking to wolfgang
munshau
director of euro intelligence he's
written for the spectator this week
about
nordstrom 2 what he calls the world's
most
controversial pipeline from the
burgeoning friendship apparently
between russia and germany so all that's
to come
in the next hour and this week we have a
special subscription offer for you too
for the first time in this long history
going all the way back to 1828
the spectator magazine will surpass the
100.000
mark if you sign up today you could be
our hundred thousand subscriber and if
you are you win a prize
with five thousand pounds including a
year's supply of paul roger champagne
and tickets to our famous summer party
covered rules per meeting of calls we'll
also send all new subscribers
this week a commemorative tote bag so
subscribe today
get your first month free at www
spectator
dot co dot u k slash 100
tv that's www.spectator
dot co dot uk slash 100 tv
as always if you subscribe to the
spectators youtube channel
and why wouldn't you because it's free
you'll never miss a program
just click the subscribe button at the
bottom right of the screen now
a very special thanks as always to
charles stanley for their continued
support
of the week in 60 minutes charles
stanley is one of the uk's leading
wealth
management firms one of the oldest
companies on the london stock exchange
we're delighted
to be partners with them so first as
always
these days covert let's start by looking
at the latest covert data
the vaccine rollout seems to be
continuing at pace
uh cases hospitalizations they're all
falling
so is it all pretty much good news now
kate over to you
thanks andrew taking a look at cases
first we continue to see a retreat of
this virus across the uk
hovering right around where cases were
in early december just as england was
coming out of its second lockdown
a similar story is playing out with
hospitalizations which currently mirror
where we were in mid-december
and when we're looking at this chart we
do have to remember that a lot of those
people
are under the age of 65. and if we look
at deaths the seven day rolling average
for copa deaths is falling as well
back to the levels we were experiencing
several weeks before we hit the peak
of the latest wave of the virus now
i'm wary of hope these days andrew but
if you were feeling hopeful
you look at the vaccine race and you
think that this might
just be the last time that we're
presented with charts
uh so stark and and and so dismal as the
ones that we've been looking at for the
past few weeks
because as the death rate falls the rate
of people being inoculated
goes up and up and this means people
with jabs
should be broadly speaking protected
from severe illness from this virus in
the future
and as you can see here the uk is still
storming ahead of its european
counterparts with over with over 13
million people
now having received at least their first
dose of the vaccine
and i'm also delighted to report based
on the spectator's vaccine tracker
that the uk isn't just set to hit its
target by the 15th of february
it's currently on track to do so two
days early which would be this saturday
we'll see if we get this surprise early
delivery but this all but guarantees
that when spectator tv
airs next week every person over the age
of 70 will have been offered a vaccine
and will be on to the next phase of
inoculating
the next priority groups understandably
the more good news we get the more
people want to know about what it means
for reopening and this is really
difficult because the government simply
hasn't laid out
its criteria for lifting restrictions
this is a chart that was produced a few
weeks ago by the coven 19
actuaries response group now this chart
estimated that we would hit the 15th of
february target
which we are on track to do that
vaccines would be roughly 70
effective and the recent data we have
around the vaccines being used in the uk
is that their efficacy rate meets this
criteria
what it didn't account for was whether
or not vaccines could in addition to
protecting people
from the virus stop them from
transmitting the virus as well
and we don't have anything conclusive on
this front but some recent data for the
oxford vaccine
suggests that it can reduce transmission
by about two-thirds
so actually you can see the chart being
updated to reflect a more positive
scenario
but the point is that what we're set to
achieve in a matter of days
should according to this modeling
reduced deaths by roughly 85 percent
in the next six weeks and hospital
emissions by 60
in the next six weeks now you'll note
that icu emissions don't go down
as much but we know that in terms of
who's in the icu right now
a lot of those numbers are made up by
the under 65s who haven't been offered
the vaccine yet
of course these people are also more
likely to leave the icu and and make a
full recovery
but even if this modeling turns out to
be broadly right that's still a very
meaningful shift
yet we just don't know what level of
cases hospitalizations or
deaths the government's willing to
tolerate to start restoring some
freedoms
and they're not giving anything away
apart from the target of the 8th of
march
when they're hoping they can start to
reopen schools we are in the dark
as to what might happen in the months
ahead yesterday you had the transport
secretary and even the prime minister
refusing to commit to foreign holidays
this year
but also domestic holidays being
possible over the summer
so it's really hard because what we're
seeing right now is actually more
measures coming in
even though more and more people are
becoming protected from the virus
the uk has adopted a stricter quarantine
policy in recent days it's going to be
implemented from next monday
mostly done in the name of preventing
new strains from entering the year
from entering the uk which they fear
could undermine vaccine efficacy
and as you can see from this chart
unfortunately the data around air
passenger travel is only produced
quarterly by the home office
so we won't know how recent policy will
affect travel for some time
but you can see here that travel has
dropped off significantly
from the first lockdown never coming
close to recovering last summer
where it was before the uh before
lockdown started
in march last year the prime minister
and prime minister's questions yesterday
said that we were down to about 20 000
passengers a day
some arriving into the uk some are
saying this still
isn't low enough others are questioning
the human impact of these travel
restrictions
even for emergency reasons making it
near impossible to travel
all of this at the moment anyway being
done so in the name of a
hypothetical uh mutant strain that the
vaccines won't respond to
at all the world health organization
bolstered the uk strategy
this week when it recommended the oxford
vaccine be used
um for all age groups above 18 and
including the over 65s
um good news for the oxford vaccine good
news for the uk strategy
but we simply don't know what it means
yet for restoring our liberty
back to you andrew thank you kate for
that fascinating charts and
graphs some good news in there but still
some serious problems as well
so a harsh new quarantine regime for
international arrivals it was brought in
by health secretary matt hancock
this week from monday people coming into
the uk
will take two tests during a 10-day
isolation period
travelers from 33 so-called redless
countries
will spend their quarantine in the
pleasure of a government built to tell
and pay nearly 2 000 pounds
for that pleasure all of this the health
sector said would help stop the new
covert 19 mutations
coming into the country from abroad this
seems to be the main fear of those in
government
a new variant against which our existing
vaccines don't work
or at least aren't so effective and that
becomes the dominant strain
central to tracking and monitoring these
mutations is the
covert 19 genomics uk consortium
colgar cog for short they have sequenced
more than 250 000 corona virus
cases more than half the world's total
and are the
front line in detecting new strains of
the disease the team is
chaired by cambridge university's
professor sharon
peacock i'm delighted to say she joins
me now professor peacock welcome to
spectator tv but before we go into some
of these just tell us a little bit about
cogs work yes thank you very much for
having me on the program and i'm really
pleased to talk about about cog uk
so we got going on the first of april
last year
and we are a network
of sequencing providers so there are 16
laboratories all across the country so
wherever you're living there's probably
one quite close to where you live
most of the sequencing sites are in in
universities
but we also have the four public health
agencies of the united kingdom working
with us
together with the welcome sanger
institute so it's our job
to take samples from people who are
positive to sequence the material that
comes from them
and then give the genome information to
public health agencies so they can use
it for public health purposes
right well it's obviously essential work
and i think we always knew are these
experts like you
always knew this this virus there would
be mutations as time
went on has there been anything
particularly surprising
about the mutations of covert 19
well you're right we we knew that
mutations were going to happen so the
virus me takes once or twice a month
but i think perhaps if you were to ask
me right at the beginning of the
pandemic
would i have expected uh it to mutate as
it has
i think one of the things that i didn't
necessarily expect
back in april uh 2020 when there were
just a small number of cases
um in the world relatively was that the
the virus would have had an opportunity
to mutate in you know 100
100 million people so every time a virus
infects somebody
it gets an opportunity to mutate and it
can only mutate when it's actually
replicating somebody because
it when it's outside of the body it's
inert it's not it's not replicating so
when it replicates it has an opportunity
to make a mistake
in its genetic code and that is when
mutations can arise
that are important so it's had a lot of
opportunity to mutate and we need to
obviously
drive down the number of cases but in
many other regards it's not that
surprising
in that through natural selection or
survival of the fittest
the virus will find ways to uh be a
fitter version of itself and
from what from what we've seen that's
either being
a faster spreading between people
and or um able to uh affect the immune
response against it
and so it's like a kind of waging a war
really if you like between
us and the the kind of evolution of the
virus which cannot obviously evolve much
faster
how concerned are you that as the virus
mutates in the way you describe
that it could mutate in a manner which
makes
the the vaccines that we're putting so
much hope on at the moment
uh less effective or perhaps even
ineffective we
we know that the variant first detected
in south africa
has uh uh means that vaccines are
are somewhat less effective but i don't
believe that they're ineffective and so
that's the first thing to say the second
thing to say is i think it's a story of
hope in
in the uk because the variants we have
are fully
you know the vaccines are fully
effective against the variants that we
have circulating at the moment
it's difficult to predict the future and
and
if i did i would probably get it wrong
um but
but i think the good news again is that
we can tweak
the vaccines and so i think that knowing
how the fact that the virus is evolving
can allow us to track it over time
to keep ahead of that and change the the
vaccines
and then stay ahead of of this as an
infectious disease threat
i think it's going to be kind of an
ongoing dance if you like with the virus
understand having eyes on the genomes
and then making those rapid changes to
the vaccine
so i think that at the moment is a good
news story we're in a good place but we
have to watch
the virus evolving does that suggest
a professor that perhaps in the autumn
or later
there will have to be some booster
vaccines to to deal with some of the
mutations
at some point yes i think at some point
but we're used to that
kind of philosophy so every year we have
a flu vaccine
and um we have to have a different
vaccine every year because there is a
different
flu strain circulating so i think that
that's
that's within our own understanding of
how we deal with infectious diseases so
uh it's possible that at some point
we'll need to have a booster dose
that's targeting a slightly different
virus uh to the one that your previous
vaccine
was targeted towards but i think that
that's all within a kind of a
scientific capability and and ability of
the government to
to orchestrate that i read that
some variants cause particular problems
and we've been hearing about uh
something called
e484k
e484k
tell us what that means yes well um
we're all becoming biologists i think
um and the reason that that is important
so what that means is
uh a mistake has been made in in the
genome of the virus
that codes for what's called the spike
protein
now the spike protein is the part of the
virus that is
uh that works to attach onto human cells
and then get into the cells it's kind of
their entry mechanism if you like so
the spike is really important and the
spike is what vaccines are generally
targeting to try and prevent that
interaction happening
now e484k is simply reflecting
a mistake in the in the kind of in the
genetic code or a change in the genetic
code
but the importance here is that changes
the amino acid
that that encodes and that can change
the structure and function either way
the virus behaves
and so this is particularly important
because it changes the way
the virus behaves the virus becomes less
susceptible
at least in laboratory to what's called
neutralization so antibodies
from people who've had infection put
against the virus
should neutralize the effect of the of
the virus
but e484k is a mutation that that
changes that dynamic
and what we know is that it's present in
the variant first detected in south
africa
and the one detected in brazil which we
call p1
and now we've seen this particular
mutation
in a very very small number of cases
popping up in
the united kingdom in our particular
variant that's circulating i would
stress that there's very small numbers
at the moment
but that's why it's of particular
concern
this concern in the government about
these mutations and particularly
importing them has led to
these much tighter controls on people
coming into the country from abroad
particularly from the 33 countries which
the government has put on its
so-called red list is in your view is
is this in order to try and keep a grip
on the mutations and to
stop the spread inside the uk is this
broadly the right way to go in your view
professor
i think it it is uh so i think what we
need is a two-pronged attack and you
you can see that playing out now so we
have uh the plans for lockdown of a
testing so we know what strains are
being
or viruses are being introduced uh what
variants are being introduced into the
country
and trying to prevent that from
happening but at the same time
the sequencing effort that we've got
going on is looking at viruses all of
the time
and when we spot something that is
concerned
of concern and the e484k change
is something that public health agencies
are watching for
then that leads to surge testing so the
surge testing goes door-to-door
it tests people for the presence of
particular in fact that's been applied
to
the south africa variant but but in
general internally we can use
increased testing and and then
contact tracing and further controls and
so i think you have to worry about
what's being introduced into the country
but also what's happening on your own
doorstep and we have this
we have the capability uh to detect that
happening
now you'll have seen that the the
success so far of uh
our country's vaccine rollout um
has somewhat increased pressure on the
government
to say to tell us when lockdown is going
to end or when the beginnings of that
process
will begin to take place do you have any
advice or guidance for the government
on that it's a it's a tricky one for
government isn't it
i think it is a tricky one and and uh
that's what sage is there for to develop
all of the evidence that they can give
to government
so i think that i would leave it to sage
to give that advice to them
but what i would say is as we're going
into
into a time of our lives when
we are not so restricted we'll have a
combination
of vaccines together with sequence data
to look at what's happening to the virus
but i think we can't let go of the idea
that we need to do
you know hands face space uh limiting
um our kind of interactions with people
in a sensible way
i think that we will obviously follow
the
the the guidance of the government but i
i think that we'll also always need to
be worrying about
hand hygiene and uh and similar
so and i think that's a good thing
because we've seen the rate of influenza
for example plummet this year
which is a very good good good good
outcome and finally professor
am i right in thinking uh because of the
work
people that yourself have been doing and
many others that
when it comes to genomics which has
suddenly become very important for us a
lot of people
probably never heard of it beforehand
that in the united kingdom we are
among the world leaders in this if not
the world leader
i think that's right i think that's
right we've sequenced nearly half of all
of the world's genomes so
for the size of our country that's quite
a feat
and we're we're further upscaling our
sequencing capability now
with the aim of sequencing as many
viruses from people
as possible professor sharon peacock
we'll leave it there thank you for all
the work you're doing
vital as it is to help keep us safe and
thank you for giving us
your time on spectator tv the week in 60
minutes
thank you thank you very much for
inviting me
now the snp continues to ride high in
the polls despite having increasingly
divided internal factions
a vaccine rollout that lag somewhat
behind its english counterpart
generally uninspiring responds to the
pandemic
no worse but not that much better than
the london response
crucial hollywood elections hollywood
elections in may
could provide the smp with the mandate
they need for a second referendum
and the unionists are only just
realizing the scale of the task at hand
douglas ross
is leader of the scottish conservatives
he's fighting to stop nicola sturgeon
from getting the majority she wants uh
he joins me now douglas ross welcome to
spectator tv
delighted to join you uh you've been
leading the
the scottish stories now for six months
um
when you took over the tories were
polling on the constituency vote at 20
percent
uh they are now pulling at 20
you've made no impact well there was one
poll this morning that actually had us
up at 23
on the constituency 21 on the list but
i'm looking at where we were
at this stage five years ago so in 2016
in the run-up to the hollywood elections
we were pulling it 15 and we went into
that election and stopped the snp who
were on roughly
similar figures as they are now and we
deny them that majority so
it shows it can be done but the only
party with the strength right across
scotland to do it
is the scottish conservatives but well
you say that
but looking at your own uh ratings the
favorability
rating for douglas ross is 16
uh the favorability rating for nicolas
sturgeon
is 59 percent uh i mean there's quite a
gap
again no real impact well
it's really difficult at the moment when
nicola sturgeon is on the bbc
every day doing a daily briefing rather
than addressing parliament as i think
people would expect the first minister
to make her statements to parliament and
i think there's ongoing discussions with
the bbc
how they have allowed the first minister
to politicize
in many cases these daily briefings and
giving her you know
a very strong platform which other
opposition parties
don't receive but i'm so
puzzled as to why you've not really made
any cut through i mean the
the snp thinks it's had a good pandemic
but the figures suggest
it hasn't really handled it that
differently from the
tories in england the vaccine rollout
has definitely been slower than england
there have been years of dismal results
under the snp now on
education and in health there are many
inquiries going on into the scottish
government and
the first minister there's a civil war
now raging in the snp
for everything from independent strategy
to gender identity i mean if you can't
cut through amid all that when are you
ever going to cut through
well there's a lot in that question so
let's just look at various different
points first of all on this
perception that nicola sturgeon has
handled this pandemic
any differently or better than the rest
of uk i think you're right to call out
because we have had
problems and failures in scotland the
same as across the uk
and the figures don't suggest it's been
any better handled by nicolas surgeon
indeed we had the shocking case last
year where people that had tested
positive in hospital
were then released into care homes and
that was as a result
of smp scottish government advice and
guidance and indeed when
are you breaking why aren't you if
that's true why aren't you breaking
through
well here's the the nub of it andrew is
when there is a vote in parliament when
all the opposition parties say actually
we need an inquiry into this as a result
of these snp
failures they fail to do that they fail
to respect parliament and indeed we've
seen that
multiple times that we can have a vote
in parliament we can hold the smpg
account
and they simply ignore it and that is
unacceptable and we do have this
situation
where there are litany of failures in
education
in health in rebuilding our economy
there has been a a sluggish
approach to business and the economy
here in scotland long before
kovid and we've just got to keep hitting
home these messages
but why then are you stuck at uh 20
in the polls or in the regional poll uh
you were around 16 in the comrades poll
i mean if the snp is as bad as you say
it is in governing scotland
certainly got a civil war going on at
the moment it doesn't seem that people
are paying much attention to you
well there is obviously a problem with
getting cut through for politics at the
moment people are worried about their
job they're worried about their
relatives or themselves getting cold but
they're worried about getting a vaccine
and it was right that the
scottish conservatives led the charge
against the asmp to get daily figures
because we knew how many people were
being vaccinated
and that's why we knew early on in this
process that scotland was lagging behind
the rest of the uk
now i'm pleased they up the ante up
their efforts but we are still
you know experiencing problems with the
vaccine like you in scotland but to go
back to your question
you're right to raise it you know it's
difficult to cut through at the moment
when people are focused
on this pandemic
boris johnson described evolution as
quote a disaster
you rejected that description but there
hasn't been an opinion poll in scotland
now for almost a year
showing a majority in favor of the union
and that the one last march uh was only
51.49 i mean
pretty much statistically nip and tuck
i mean if you are a unionist in what way
has devolution not been a disaster
well i'm absolutely a unionist and the
prime minister clarified his remarks
remember
this is a prime minister who got that
top job because of devolution his time
is made of london
it ensured he was uh you know in a
position to then stand again for
parliament to become foreign secretary
and ultimately to be prime minister of
the united kingdom so he understands and
it fully respects how devolution works
but like me he's frustrated
that after 14 years of devolution in the
hands of the smp in scotland
we're seeing so many of our public
services suffering
and yet again you have no chance of
winning this election
well we're a long way out we've got to
look at the opinion polls as i say look
at how we are comparing now
compared to where we were five years ago
in this stage if you've been
interviewing ruth davidson you'd have
been saying the exact same thing you
can't stop an snp majority
and we did we're talking about a
an administration in edinburgh that's
been in power for what
14 years and his odds-on favorite to be
re-elected
again perhaps with an overall majority
well we've got to see how the campaign
goes as i see andrew you know if you've
been sat here five years ago you'd have
been saying to ruth davidson
there was no chance that the scottish
conservatives could have stopped the snp
having that majority
and they did many people forget this but
nicolas surgeon went into that
election in 2016 with the majority and
came out of it
having lost the majority because the
scottish conservatives more than doubled
their number of msps
if nicola sturgeon either gets an
overall majority or is still clearly
the dominant uh power in holyrood and
forms another government
uh and proceeds by to to hold a
referendum
without the agreement of westminster
it's within the
jargon it's without a section 30
order um what should the british
government do
well i know the scottish conservatives
will take no part in a wildcat
illegal referendum i want to focus on
scotland's recovery
after covert rather than another
referendum that's where every
political party should be aiming their
strengths their abilities and
their uh you know the mind of government
to make sure scotland gets back up and
running
after covet but absolutely i'm not going
to take part in any wildcat illegal
referendum and it just shows where the
snp have got to
they just want a referendum over
anything else and they are not willing
to
you know focus on what needs to be done
in scotland over the next five years
they want to rip us apart from the rest
of the united kingdom
and even if that means holding an
illegal referendum
so just to be clear under your
leadership the scottish tories would not
participate in in a referendum that was
not
sanctioned by the section 30 and that
you would encourage your voters or
supporters
to stay at home yes absolutely
boycott it and show it for the reckless
referendum it is it's one that takes
away attention
and time from the real serious problems
we have here in scotland right now
for our education system the fact that
the snp are building hospitals that
can't take any patients
the fact that our economy is struggling
the fact that our justice system
seems to support the criminals more than
the victims these are where our focus
has to be and recovery
but rather than a referendum which if it
doesn't have that section 30 order then
it is not the gold standard referendum
that nicola sturgeon herself
said the 2014 referendum was but if
nicola sturgeon wins an overall majority
and fights the election on a clear
request for a mandate to give her a
mandate for a second referendum
and she gets an overall majority as a
right
what as a result by what right do you
have to refuse of that second referendum
the fact that we were told just over six
years ago
that the 2014 referendum was a you know
a once in a generation vote that had
been
accepted by both sides as the gold
standard that's how you agree
for the uk government to give the
section 30 order to agree the date the
question
all of this yet now nicholas sturgeon
wants to rip that up
and appease her nationalist supporters
and said she would have a wildcat
illegal referendum enemy
what does that say to people up and down
scotland right now who are worried about
their job worried about their school for
their their son or daughter worried
about their health service
it for their you know family who can't
get into these hospitals at the smp
build that can't take any patients it
just shows that nicholas surgeon's
priority
is to the snp not the scottish people
but in the 2014 referendum the unionist
side your site
told scottish voters that the one sure
way to secure
scotland's continued uh participation in
the european union
was to vote to remain in the united
kingdom
how did that work out and then the
united kingdom had a democratic vote one
that was agreed by parliament supported
by politicians to ask the public if they
wanted to leave
or remain in the european union that is
how you deal with these
referendums you go through a process
which is clear
in law but you never mentioned that in
2014 and tony
in 2014 when the snp campaigned on
leaving the uk
joining the eu as an independent member
your side said
there's no guarantee the eu will accept
you the only sure way you can remain in
the eu
is to stay in the uk and that turned out
to be
fundamentally wrong uh statement to the
scottish voters
well the scottish voters also knew there
was an opportunity if the conservatives
won a majority
in the election the following year that
it could be a manifesto commitment to
have
an in-out referendum on our place in
europe but then
let's also look at what the snp told the
people of scotland if you vote for
independence
will pay for everything with oil at over
a hundred dollars a barrel well oil
hasn't been over a hundred dollars a
barrel
at any point since that 2014 referendum
and that was certainly a misleading
statement from the snp
just one of many when we uh got on to
this
part of our interview but my original
question to you was
um what do you think or how would you
advise the government in london
to prevent or respond to
a a wildcat referendum
what's the answer well i assume the
government in london would look at what
the
scottish conservatives are doing and
under my leadership i'm saying boycotted
don't get into this fight with the snp
over a wildcat referendum that distracts
from the uk government
scottish conservatives and what i think
every political party in scotland and
across the uk should be focused on
over this next five-year parliament
which is recovery rather than
referendums
if it's a wildcat or some would call it
i think probably probably
you don't source would call that an
illegal referendum
should police scotland local authorities
returning officers
should they participate in the
administration of such a referendum
well there's two other people to mention
before to even get sir andrew what about
the lord advocate who is appointed by
the government so if nicolas sturgeon
is still the first minister and taking
this through her political appointment
as the
lord advocate in a neutral way but he is
still appointed by the first minister
must give advice to the first minister
and say this is out with the remit and
the authority of the scottish parliament
and then the presiding officer of the
scottish parliament before
any vote is held on an illegal wildcat
referendum should be saying this is out
with the remit of the scottish
parliament how about nicholas surging
you deal with
education with health with policing
they're all within your remit focus on
them
rather than this wildcat legal
referendum
so if scottish ministers government
ministers proceed with what
your view would be an illegal wildcat
your words referendum
should they face criminal charges they
they have to be answerable for their
actions
why are they taking forward these plans
illegal
wildcat referendum plans in the middle
of a pandemic
when not only we are still trying to get
on top of the health emergency
we will have an economic emergency to to
fight
in the next few months and years ahead
so just for clarification uh whatever
the outcome of the holy elections in may
scottish tories will oppose a second
independent referendum
under any circumstances during the next
session of the parliament
absolutely i don't want another divisive
referendum and people know
that across scotland the scottish
conservatives are the strongest party
to stand up for their interest for
scotland to remain an important part of
the united kingdom
to benefit from being part of that
family of four nations and to give so
much
to our four nations of the united
kingdom the
traditional response to the snp's demand
for independence or a referendum
has been to grant more powers to the
holyrood
parliament are you in favor of that i'd
just love to see the holyrood parliament
using the powers it's currently got you
know they
jumped up and down and called for more
powers over social security and then the
snp found
they didn't have the capacity to deal
with that and they transferred them back
to westminster
and the uk government to handle for a
number of years so let's see
the scottish government actually using
the powers it's got right now
so just to be clear you would oppose
any more powers for the scottish
parliament for the moment
right now i want to see the scottish
parliament using the powers it's got
are you worried i mean the problems the
labour party has had
uh in scotland in recent years has
allowed the scottish stories to become
the second party
and in some ways the the unionist vote
has called
coalesced around the scottish tories
but there could be signs with the new
leader that the labour party
will be getting its act together maybe
not in time for the holy
elections or maybe it will be in in time
uh
are you worried that they could supplant
you
as the main opposition to the snp well i
don't think they are in opposition to
the snp and that's the problem under
their former leader
richard leonard i offered to work with
him to say look if we can work together
after the next election to get rid of
this tired and feeling
snp government will you do it and he
said no so i then made the offer to
monica lenin and anna salwarp and they
announced they were standing for labour
leader
and they turned that down as well so
they don't want to work with other
parties who support scotland's place in
the union
who will stand up for scotland to get
rid of the snp
and in fact we see in councils across
scotland they're actually perfectly
happy
to work with the snp so i think it's
clear to people that the labour party
are still stuck in this middle ground
and they're more likely to side with the
nationalists and keep them in power
than work with that pro-union party to
get rid of the snp
but the may elections for hollywood will
be the first real test of your
leadership
uh if you end up in third place
if labor does become second because
we're all assuming the snp will be first
if you're in third place that will
be a serious blow to your leadership
won't it well i'm not putting a limit on
my ambitions for the scottish
conservatives in this election and i'm
up for this fight i'm really excited
about the positive policies
we're going to bring forward to take to
people across the country and show the
failures of this snp government
and indeed the failures of parties like
labour who are not willing to stand up
and be counted here
but if you beca if you came third behind
the snp
and labor that would be a problem for
you
i'm not going to predict where i'm going
to come andrew but i'm sure i'll be
quite happy to come on again
and discuss the results on spectator tv
at once the people of scotland have cast
their votes and we know the outcome
oh douglas ross we'll hold you to that
thank you for the promise
and thank you for joining us on
spectator v on
tv on the week in 60 minutes the leader
of the scottish
conservatives douglas ross now remember
if you subscribe to the spectators
youtube channel for free you'll never
miss an episode
just click the subscribe button at the
bottom of the screen
now political follow-up to all of that
i'm joined by the spectators political
team james forsyth
the political editor katie bowles our
deputy political editor to discuss
what they just said james what did you
make of that i i mean the challenge for
douglas ross is this
is as you said jackson carl august was
left with the kind of whiskey in the
revolver
because he wasn't doing well enough in
the polls have the poles moved enough in
the scottish story's favor that that's
the first question
secondly if anasawa as is expected wins
the labour leadership
that will be a more impressive scottish
labor leadership than that has been for
some time
and so you know does that make it harder
for the scottish tourists to coalesce
the union vote behind them but
i think you really heard the difficulty
there which is you listed all of the
problems in the smp
and this is this the the divisions in
the snp are
spectacular to put it mildly you have
uh the current first minister and the
previous first minister the two biggest
figures in snp history
uh at war uh and uh we've with one of
them seem
we've been seemingly intent on
destroying each other uh you have
uh the snp's most accomplished
westminster parliamentarian being sacked
from the front bench
and clearly not intending to go quietly
yet
uh the snp still have this commanding
lead in the polls
and i mean the question becomes this
which is you know in the run-up to
the uh hollywood elections in may you
know
can the opposition parties actually make
some progress and
and deny the snp that overall majority
or are they simply now in such a
powerful position
but even with all of these internal
divisions and tensions
that they can still produce a majority
and i think you saw there in that
interview
how difficult it will be for the
unionist side
if the snp win a majority on an explicit
india f2 platform
they're gonna the argument that now is
not the time because of kovid
i i think will work for a year or two
but i think it's hard to see that being
a sufficient argument
for the entirety of the parliament katie
mr ross sits on the conservative benches
in westminster
i understand he intends to remain on
these
benches even if he becomes an msp and
leads the scottish tourism hollywood
parliament
uh how is he regarded by conservative
colleagues there
i think there's a mix of views towards
douglas ross i think that if you speak
to his
colleagues in terms of fellow scottish
conservative mps
uh i think there is a fair amount of
support there
i think that if you look at the
difficult time in the 2019 election that
scottish mps
who were conservative had there is a
sense that to survive i think is a
bonding activity given several lost
their seats
but i i do think doug ross's tactics in
terms of how vocal he's been
uh to criticize boris johnson he hasn't
really hidden
some of his criticisms of boris johnson
in fact he's given several interviews
suggesting for example nicholas sturgeon
is a better communicator
i think that has ruffled feathers i
think there are some in number 10 who
think that is a short-sighted approach
criticizing the prime minister might
help you
be noticed in scotland in the short term
but they worry about what that would
mean in the long term when you start
making cases for the union
it could undermine it so i think that
there are some who who do worry about
some of his tactics
james let me come back to you we've had
this quarantine plan it's been a long
while coming
uh for international truck arrivals and
then out of the blue
mr hancock says that if you lie about
where you've come from
you could face 10 10 years in prison
10 years more than you would probably
get for killing your granny
what's the point of that i think the
length of the sentence
suggests a worry that people don't take
this entirely seriously you know if if
if there was a general public perception
that anyone who lied on the form would
be caught
you wouldn't need to have a ten year
sentence you know six months would do it
i think most people wouldn't
would risk six months in prison for a
10-day hotel quarantine so
i think in some ways it's an admission
of the limits of their abilities to to
track people down
i also think it it kind of risks being a
slight kind of sledgehammer to crack a
nut
it is so over the top that that people
struggle to take it entirely seriously
um i mean the government's chief law uh
jonathan jones who spectacularly quit as
the government's chief law officer has
offered to eat his face mask if anyone
goes to prison for 10 years for this
offense and i do find it hard to believe
that
um anyone will we had a very good piece
on coffee house by barrister pointing
out that
because of the delays and the backlogs
in the court system no one would
actually stand trial for this offence
until 2023 and
i think it's hard to believe that in
those circumstances the judge would send
someone down to 10 years for not having
filled in their passenger locator form
correctly
the tory back benches were in a
rebellious mood not too long ago
challenging the government
over the lockdown and so on um
but they've lost a bit of that mood now
they just are they going to roll over
and accept this
i think in the short term they will
accept travel restrictions
however the 10-year sentence idea
for breaking the rules on a form has
definitely
led to an explosion of anger again and
the usual suspects yes are coming
forward i think figures such as steve
baker don't like it
but also you have former attorney
generals um
criticizing it just on a legal basis but
i do think it is
reigniting that debate over
restrictions and i think this is all
then lead up to boris johnson setting
out a road map in a week or so's time on
the way out of lockdown
and i think that the 10-year sentence is
one thing but there's a creeping concern
amongst tory mps that the goalposts are
changing on easing lockdown
and instead of just vaccinating and
protecting the most vulnerable
this could be now about suppressing the
vaccine indefinitely because of new
variants
and i think that's what we're going to
hear more about in the coming days and
weeks
all right let's leave it there i'm just
getting some breaking news
as we record this uh this afternoon
coming from scotland the spectator's
been in court
uh to try and get what we believed are
important documents
into the investigation into how the alex
salmon's
judicial review was handled and
according to the guardian the spectator
has won its legal challenge
over the salmon trial court orders that
lady dorian who was the judge
is going to vary an order and it will
now allow according to this report
mr salmond and jeff aberdeen who was mr
simon's chief of staff
their evidence to be published something
that the
public enquirer the parliamentary
inquiry into this issue
has refused to do so if that breaking
news
is uh accurate and it comes from
seven carol on twitter who's a guardian
correspondent
covering this then that's quite a
breakthrough for the spectator there'll
be more
on our website as the day goes on these
are complicated matters though
and we'll need to study everything in
detail before we're sure that this
is a good result for the spectator good
result
for holding government to accountability
good result
for freedom of the press let's turn to
our last
topic today uh in this week's spectator
wolfgang munchau
writes about what he calls the most
controversial gas
pipeline in the world it certainly is
it's called nordstrom 2
and would directly supply natural gas
from russia to germany
european leaders are furious of the
plans while biden's secretary of state
anthony blinken said
he's going to do whatever he can to stop
its completion
so why is germany sidling up to russia
how will it
change the eu's relationship with the us
wolfgang is director of euro
intelligence many of you remember when
he wrote
excellent columns for the financial
times he joins us now
wolfgang thanks for being on spectator
tv just give us before we come to the
issues that are making the headlines at
the moment
just give us a bit of background to how
not stream 2 came into effect
well it all happened with um with
angela merkel's decision to cut off the
nuclear power
industry in 2011 she decided to face to
accelerate the phase out
and that made germany more dependent on
gas and
oil for its energy consumption and
germany is a country with
a lot of manufacturing industries so it
has a very large demand
for energy compared to most countries of
its size
and the only country that was able to
the only source of energy that was
readily available was gas
gas from russia and the idea of north
stream two it's a pipeline that goes
from
uh from the russian end of the baltic
sea through
swedish danish waters into germany has
been to
supply gas directly from russia to
germany bypassing ukraine
uh critically enough and that has been
one of the reasons why the u.s
administration has been so critical of
this project
and of course because it makes germany
even more dependent on you
on russian gas than it already is
and the the problem right now is that
germany actually
is already dependent on russian girls
because what happens if
germany were to yield to u.s demands
and stop the pipeline for example in
protest against the arrest of navalny
um then the russians have threatened to
cut
off germany from its existing supplies
and that could
conceivably produce an acute energy
crisis right now
so this is a real sort of almost life
and death issue for the german
government and they
are going to some extreme measures to
make sure that this russian gas is
flowing
and that this pipeline is the const the
construction of the pipeline is
completed
the polish response to the the problem
of gas supplies was to
build a number of new lng
harbors places where lng can be
offloaded this a lot of it coming from
the united states which is now a major
gas
exporter was that never considered an
option
for germany yes the germans have
considered the option they have even
offered to build a terminal
um what has emerged this week is that
the german finance minister
has actually offered to to spend a whole
billion euros
uh on on constructing an lng
terminal uh the the problem is is that
the existing lng terminals in europe are
not fully utilized in any case
um and from an american point of view um
the the issue is is that
you know it's the dependence on russian
gas once this pipeline is flowing there
won't be much demand for lng
um lng is a more complicated technology
this stuff has to be you know
it's liquid it has to be you know turned
into it's more expensive move around
yes it's it's it's it's so so the
the issue is not the germans think it's
it's commercial the germans think the
americans just want to sell their lng to
them instead of you know
this isn't this is not a fair
characterization of the american
position
for the american this is a strategic
thing as well because because you know
germany is a is dependent um it's part
of nato
it's uh but it makes itself dependent uh
on
on russia so this is the american
position it's not only the republican
administration's position it was the
position of the trump administration
but it is a bipartisan majority in
congress that has passed a law
in 2019 to stop uh to
to impose sanctions on companies
involved in this project
uh and and the republicans and the biden
administration
seems intent from what we know so far to
um
to follow this uh follow this law and
use this law
so just to to to categorize the
geopolitical concern about this pipeline
at base is it a concern
uh germany will be if for a
chunk of its energy needs it will be
dependent on russia
and that that will make it
more cozy with russia it would be less
likely to stand up to russia at times
when nato and the west and germany's
allies
need to stand up to russia is that the
fundamental concern
that is indeed the fundamental concern
and what i would add to this con
is that this situation has already
arisen i do not think germany is at this
moment
willing already to stand up to russia
because it is dependent on russia
already
and this pipeline will make it more
dependent and there are also political
links between the social democratic
party in germany
and russia we remember that gerhard
schroeder the former chancellor
is the supervisory board chairman of the
north stream 2
project he's a personal friend of putin
he once called putin
a first-rate democrat um
so he is a you know the social
democratic leadership including the
president of germany frank walterstein
is also very close to russia and has and
this week
said that the the pipeline was something
that germany owed to russia
because of the second world war um the
social democrat-run state of uh macklin
book four permanent this is the
state in the in the northeastern part of
germany
has um accepted money from the north
stream 2 company
to build a foundation which serves as a
as a as a as an as a way to circumvent
you with sanctions because this
your sanctions are not directed against
state and government-owned
entities so they are playing hardball
to have to to put this mindfully
i've been reading you your excellent uh
article in this week's spectator
wolfgang it does seem that there's
there's a there's a russian lobby at the
heart of the german political
elite is that unfair to say that
and if it's not unfair why is there this
russian lobby
the russian lobby is is um it has a long
tradition it is um
it is it is there is a a committee
called the east
the east committee of the german economy
and that committee is very powerful
compared to the national rifle
association in the united states in
terms of its influence in
in the german and in german business it
has a interesting
it it includes a lot of companies
especially you know the
people who've been exporting to russia
now they have complained bitterly about
the sanctions that germany you know
mackel
to her credit she she you know she uh
was
instrumental in in in organizing these
european
sanctions against russia but she also
made sure that these sanctions wouldn't
become too you know would not extend to
to energy
so these sanctions are relatively
wouldn't say symbolic but they are not
as big as they could be or should be
and these people are now uh you know are
putting there's a
massive lobby an industrial lobby that
you know that's influential in the spd
parts of the cdu the so the christian
democracy
uh the csu uh so these are the parties
that are most
most likely to be you know you know
having these these links to russia
uh the the party that is the least
likely or that is most opposed to
nordstrom the actually the only party
that is opposed to nordstrom are the
greens
and we have this extraordinary position
that the us position and the position of
the green party in germany are
completely aligned
uh that hasn't happened before strange
bad fellas indeed
the the role of gerhard schroeder
formula
former social democratic chancellor of
germany his role looking from the
outside
just seems extraordinary i i mean
alex salmon former first minister of
scotland he
he was beyond the pill because he
presents a
a program on what we used to call russia
today
that's all he just pray and he's no
longer an active politician
uh gerhard schroeder's relationship with
mr putin and the kremlin
i find it hard to think that any british
public figure
could survive what gohard schroeder has
done
well the thing is further you know
survival is no longer in
a matter for german politics or for
germany
the german public is reacting similarly
to that
uh this is not this is not accepted this
is not an accepted standard there is no
law against this i th
the government has since
sharpened the procedures against
politicians leaving government until you
know
getting into the employment of some some
someone
but in in general there is a you know
this is assumed to be
uh his choice um and
um one would assume that the united
states would have
would also not be able to stop mr trump
from acting
the way he will act or wants to act
after his presidency
hasn't described putin's russia as a
well-functioning democracy but i
understand
mr schroeder's come quite close to that
he has he has he
um he has i mean he he's a personal
friend of putin putin came to his
birthday
and you know they are they have been
close um on a person on a personal level
but even michael he who is not close to
putin you know when they meet they speak
russian
um um it's it's you know there is a deep
understanding in german
in german certainly in the german
society or in in the sort of political
society
um of russia russia is a country that
germans understand quite well
if you know if you look at eu countries
you know
the understanding of russia is is fairly
high in germany relative to that of
of other countries and there is a a link
i mean i always think the germans look
at russia the way the dutch look at
germany
it's sort of the the smaller the smaller
country looking at the bigger country in
sort of in a mixture of fear and
admiration and you know that's the
relationship that that
that that the two countries have had
historically
the other the other geopolitical
significance that comes out of your
your uh article with gang is that
you we all assume that with the
departure of trump
and with a a more traditional american
president back in the
white house a pro-nato transatlantic
uh president that that would mark a
reset of european
american relations there would still be
arguments there always are there were
arguments
under clinton arguments going back to
eisenhower
under reagan but that it would be reset
in a more
normal way it is possible is it not that
the row of this pipeline
is going to be a huge spanner in the
works of that
i would think so the biden
administration will change the tone and
that's already changed the tone towards
germany
and uh but yeah mackel herself has
concluded that
the and i think rightly concluded that
trumpism wasn't defeated in the last
election you know trump was defeated the
there was a clear election result but it
was a narrow election result
trump got some 70 million plus votes
um this uh you know the trumpism is
still there it might return
so germany has concluded that and
along with france that they needed to be
you know autonomous in terms of its
foreign policy this is not you know as a
description of the status today
because they are not autonomous but it's
certainly a long-term policy goal
uh to become less dependent on the
united states uh but they are still
dependent on the united states so we are
in this sort of position where these
sort of ambitions and the reality are
um a part
final question for you wolfgang
despite the biden administration's
dislike of this pipeline and
many of you i mean the british don't
like it either i think there's quite a
few european allies and not
at all the eu as i understand it isn't
that keen on it
either but despite all that is it too
late
to stop now is is the pipeline
happening going to happen almost close
to a done deal
um it's it's they they the germans were
quite optimistic in december that they
could get this done there was this the
ship
this russian pipeline vessel which was
dispatched
to to um to to complete the remaining
you know five percent
but the problem that has arisen is that
companies
in charge of certifying of safety
certification
have refused to uh to actually do the
job
because they are subject to u.s
sanctions and as of now there
is no plan b for uh for that there is no
no no no company available willing
willing to do this now they might come
up with something so it is a bit of a
race against the time
the idea is to complete the remaining
five percent
and get the stuff switched on before the
americans do anything
but so far this isn't happening and the
interesting when i speak to both sides
is both sides are absolutely convinced
that their position will ultimately
prevail the americans are absolutely
convinced that they will stop it
and in germany virtually everybody is
telling you that
gas will flow in the end so you know
somebody will
in the end lose out and at the moment i
think that
you know my my hunch is that that it
will flow at reduced rates that that
will be the compromise at some point
but this won't be easy to work so there
may be some
some kind of compensation payment that
germany pays to russia or something like
that
there is a compromise possible because
you can the amount of gas you send
through a pipeline is
um you know is one can regulate it so
that would probably be or a that is a
possible compromise
okay well the story is not over yet
wolfgang we'll come back to you as it
develops uh
for the moment wolfgang mantra director
of euro intelligence uh
thank you for your call in the spectator
this week and thank you uh for appearing
on spectator tv
and that's it for this week thanks to
all of our guests and once again to our
very special sponsor
charles stanley sponsoring the week in
60 minutes
charles stanley is one of the uk's
leading wealth management firms one of
the oldest firms on the london stock
exchange now remember this week
we have a special subscription offer the
spectator
magazine passes the hundred thousand
subscriber mark
he has a hundred thousand subscribers
now for the spectator the
hundred thousands will happen this week
and if you sign up today you could be
that
hundred thousand subscriber we haven't
been there
since we were founded in 1828 so if you
are
that one that magical six figure
subscriber then you'll win a prize worth
five
thousand pounds including a year's
supply of paul roger champagne
tickets to our famous summer party
covert permitting
we'll also send all new subscribers in
this hundred thousand week
a commemorative tote bank subscribe
today and get your first
month free at www spectator dot co dot
uk
forward slash 100 tv that's spectator
dot co dot
uk 100 tv it's been a week for
or a year of the spectator of zeros our
10 000th
edition uh published last year and now
our hundred thousand subscriber as
always
send us your thoughts to spectator tv at
spectator.com.uk
and join us again next week but for now
bye bye
[Music]
you